no son
yeah
[Music]
so
easier
Lavie attorney is going to give us a
survey of practical participants Thanks
so before we start I want to thank the
organizers and also I need to thank my
coefficient in respective so compared to
you balls talk this one is going to be
lets say a gear shift so this is gonna
be more like a system Z or implementers
view of the landscape and the goal is to
look at like concrete costs and
applications and maybe at the end I'll
present my own sort of wish list so by
now everyone's kind of familiar with the
jumping off point but the idea is we
have a verifier that has some
computation I'll use five for that
throughout and there's some input X and
some output Y maybe it's just a bit one
or zero and the the prover is gonna
convince the verifier that the y equals
five x maybe with a short proof and four
zero knowledge we have this additional
requirement the prover has a witness and
the proof doesn't reveal the witness
approximately so as we saw and you've
also talked there's a lot of the sort of
theoretical work that establishes the
basis here and in the last decade or so
there's been what I think is kind of an
astonishing amount of like practical
work like everything on this slide
that's on the columns it somehow reports
on something that they built and tested
so that's just to me just like
mind-blowing and in fact um mike wolfish
gave a talk about four years ago right
here and I think that column existed
then maybe a tiny bit at the top here so
like I think the rate may even be
accelerating so at some point will reach
the proof singularity so but but it's
possible in spite of that that I've
missed yours and please in that case
it's ignorant not malice and there's a
little bit more room here so just just
tell me and I'll add it okay
so we're gonna try and get a handle on
this and we already saw this a little
bit and you've also talked but we can
try and cut apart these things by you
know any number of desiderata and cost
so obviously we can worry about the
provers time generating the proof the
verifiers time the size of the proof or
a communication if it's interactive we
could worry about cryptographic as
functions we could worry about trusted
setup whether to set up is universal or
applies only to a single computation we
can worry about interactivity zero
knowledge the model of computation or
expressiveness and this is actually only
a subset of the zoo that we saw before
I'm not mentioning things like public
verifiability or this sort of thing but
so I think you've already said this but
I hope that if you take anything away
from this talk it's just that this is
some some like mega trade-off space and
we're not going to get like one optimal
point in the trade-off space it's more
like if you know what your application
is then you can find a point where life
is pretty good but this also means like
this is okay from from a researchers
perspective Henry hates life is good
this is okay from a researchers
perspective because like this means that
there's just more to explore but but
from an implementers perspective like if
I have an application and I go and look
at this space there's like some analysis
paralysis right I was just like frozen
in awe of all the sites on the last page
so but let's try and start to break that
paralysis by taking the systems apart
okay so we have some computation Phi of
X and W and we can think about a system
for it for making one of these proof
protocols as sort of something that
converts from our computation Phi into
two new computations one that the
verifier runs and one that the prove our
runs and we can kind of think about that
happening in two separate stages which
I'll call the front end and the back end
so in the front end the the computation
Phi is is somehow converted or compiled
and I'm gonna use the word compiler more
like GCC unless like you know the way
that you've all did but a compiler that
goes from Phi to some intermediate
representation and usually that's an
arithmetic circuit but it's not always
and the goal of the front end is to
construct that representation such that
it's satisfaction is tantamount to
correct execution of Phi and then the
back end applies some of the machinery
that we saw and somehow turns this into
the the actual like concrete steps that
the verifier does and that the prover
does and so so this is sort of in the
operating table and we're going to start
to dissect
but I want to give you a couple warnings
first so first I'm gonna try and do yeah
yes let's see yes so this is more like
the the protocol for or sorry the
pipeline for going from fie without
inputs just the description of phi2 a
description of behaviors for the
behaviors for the prover in verifier and
then when the verifier improver actually
run those programs
that's where X and W enter does that
make sense okay
so a couple quick warnings I'm gonna try
and sort of connect the proof machinery
to you Vols talk but in doing so it's a
little bit of a taxonomy and I apologize
the slide gets a little dunce but
there's smoother sailing after that and
the second thing is with with some of
these papers it's a little difficult
sometimes to decide is this a front-end
is this a back-end is it both is it
neither so if there's something that
looks like that maybe should be a
front-end instead of it back end or
there's one that I lost maybe I just
have a different idea of what
constitutes a back-end than you do so
sorry about that
okay so let's try and connect to the
last talk so we heard about linear PCPs
from ICAO seven and the the
instantiation that people tend to use
quadratic arithmetic programs and the
earliest practical systems in this area
were based on that
so pepper and ginger used the hata mart
PCP and then basically everything else
uses qap and let's see pepper ginger and
zatar are interactive as we'll see later
and and the rest of these are not
interactive but we can worry about that
in a second so the other thing I should
mention is this ellipses here hides a
lot of refinements to the Pinocchio
protocol so these the back end the
Pinocchio back end is like a very strong
strongly deployed piece of work and
there have been a lot of refinements to
it
so another line of work starts from
interactive proofs or multi prove
interactive proofs so at the bottom all
these systems owe a debt to G K ro8
which showed how to make the interactive
proofs where the honest proof of runs in
polynomial time and also to CMT 12 which
showed how to go from sort of quadratic
or cubic complexity to quasi linear
complexity
and then they were 13 giraffe and Libra
successively refine this until we get
sort of linear approver complexity for
the problems that these systems can
handle and then on top of that we have
like zkv sequel and higher acts and
Libra and Spartan that show how we can
make zero knowledge proof out of these
things um so I guess I should also
mention maybe Bloomberg failure Boo
walfish 14 belongs down here not up here
but I ran out of space that is based on
multi prove interactive proof it's
called clover and Spartan inherits from
that and removes the second prove er and
replaces it with cryptography to get a
zero knowledge proof so you've also
talked about MPC in the head and the
practical implementations there are zk
busey kb plus plus which refines it and
li hero and i know we'll see a talk
about lechero later and another line of
work we can think of as kind of may be
generalizing sigma protocols it sort of
ends with the bulletproof slime ends for
now with the bulletproof slime and this
one gives like very short like
concretely short log sized proofs and
then there's aurora and stark which
build on IOPS and also on the the
arguments and CS proofs of helium and
McCauley and last but not least we have
the polynomial delegation based schemes
like Sonic and I think we hear about
Sonic this afternoon um but this is sort
of based on the polynomial commitments
of Kade's uh Bharucha and Goldberg ten
and then some later refinements to that
so this is too neat in some sense
because it seems like everything just
inherits from one line of research and
that's totally not true there's all
kinds of cross-linking here so let me
give you a few examples so sonic uses
the same arithmetic as bulletproof
switch comes from the work of Moodle at
all and the line of work that includes
zkv sequel vram and Libra uses
polynomial delegation or sort of a
follow-on to that
by Papa month or she and Tomas Xia that
is verifiable polynomial delegation and
some zero-knowledge variants of that and
another and another example I think
we'll hear from musu on this Leggero you
can think of as sort of an interactive
PCP
which is sort of in the line of Opie's
maybe we can think of it as a
restriction on IOPS so this is an
oversimplification but kind of gives us
pointers to where the intellectual debts
are so we can also start slicing by set
up in cryptographic assumptions so when
I say trusted set up here I mean a
specific thing I mean we have a
computation that the outputs what we
call a structured reference string and
the reference string is used during
proving and verification and the
important thing to know is that if the
structured reference string is generated
dishonestly then you can prove false
statements so you can see why we don't
maybe don't want to have a structured
reference string and in fact there's
been a lot of work on getting rid of
structured reference strings recently
but some systems do use a trusted set up
and they use some of them use what's
called a universal trusted set up and
the idea here is that once we've done
the set up once then at least up to some
size bound we can execute any
computation that we want using that same
trusted set up and within this category
we can divide a little more finely sonic
has this very cool property as I guess
we'll see in the next talk that the the
trusted set up is actually updatable
which means if somebody's already done
this set up then I can take it and run a
computation on it and get out a new set
up and then I should trust that that one
is okay and then you can also believe
that I actually correctly translated the
old trusted set up to the new one
so maybe we can all be happy and we can
think about this as maybe a slow-motion
multi-party computation right I do it
and then like tomorrow somebody else
does it and eventually everyone has
contributed their own randomness to the
to the reference string and then finally
most of the early practical systems in
the area rely on a trusted set up
procedure that is per computation so if
you want to run a different computation
then you have to run a new trust itself
so within even these categories we can
break things down a little further so
let's ask what are the what are the
assumptions the the interactive proof
and multi prove earner active proof
based schemes have unconditional
guarantees not zero knowledge and of
course they require interaction this
group here is a k boozey kb plus plus li
hero Aurora and Stark are based on
collision resistant hash functions and
they can be made non interactive in the
random Oracle model and there
post quantum secure and let's see
bulletproof hi Rex Parton and also
pepper ginger sitar are built on some
diffie-hellman ish assumption and
although I guess we should say pepper
ginger and zatar are private coin and
non zero knowledge and bulletproof hyrax
and Spartan our public coin and can be
made and zero knowledge so they can be
made non interactive and then we have
the systems from based on Pinocchio
protocol and also the ones that use
polynomial delegation and those are some
sort of knowledge of exponent or related
assumption nowadays I think most
everyone who's using Pinocchio style
protocols is actually using the yunsik
wrote 16 argument which is in the
generic group model so that's stronger
than knowledge of exponent in the sense
that in the generic group model you can
prove a knowledge of exponent of type
statement and then I should say Sonic is
not actually it's a little stronger than
the standard model but a little weaker
than the generic group model is in the
algebraic robot okay so okay we're gonna
we're gonna keep going we're gonna keep
going so we're gonna slice one more time
we could ask a couple different
questions actually but these are quicker
I promise so we could ask like how does
the per computation trust is setup
amortize because this is also sort of
interesting right and it turns out that
the the Pinocchio based protocols once
you've run the trust it set up for a
computation then you just get to keep
using that set up forever whereas in the
earlier work the pepper ginger zatar
work you have to run the trusted set up
and then you can use it for a batch of
computations but once you're done with
the batch you got to rerun the trusted
set up one more okay it's just one last
one ok so then within Universal trusted
setup we could ask what is what is the
cost of universality and it turns out
that so some of these systems we're
gonna see this later in more detail some
of these systems get universality
basically by emulating a universal
circuit on top of arithmetic circuits
and so that emulation has some cost
built into it on the other hand so
that's like the lip snark with VN tiny
RAM and B Ram have have this flavor and
then something like Libre or sonic the
universality is sort of at a lower level
it's more inherent to the protocol and
so there's not there's entire of
abstraction where we have to pay first
for a universal circuit
okay we're done with that all right so
now that we've gone through some of the
desiderata oh yes okay now that we've
gone oh now that we've gone through some
of the desiderata let's look at concrete
performance tech numbers so it's
important to be clear that one graph is
not the answer to your performance
questions like this is one application
and this application tells us how these
things perform on this one application
but we're trying to get some like sort
of equal footing idea of how things work
and this is an approximation of the
truth so the benchmark here is a proof
of knowledge of the leaves of a Merkel
tree so the public input is the root of
the tree and the witness is the
purported leaves and then the the
checking computation just recomputes the
the root using sha-256 in this case and
then checks for equality so the the
x-axis is the height of the tree and the
y-axis here is proof size and kilobytes
so you know kind of going from the
bottom to the top lib snark which is the
only one on this slide that uses trust
it set up lib snark super small bullet
proof things start to grow a little bit
Libra hyrax
what what is this Aurora lick arrow and
Stark and then finally at the top the
zkb plus plus which goes you know and
most of these are sort of hundreds of
kilobytes at most maybe five hundred
kilobytes and then this one goes from
you know a megabyte to hundreds of
megabytes so this is this is sort of the
range of proof sizes and maybe one thing
other than just like reading data off
the slide to you that I can point out is
look we all know that asymptotics aren't
the whole story but there are a couple a
couple specific examples here that I
think put that in sharp relief so one is
bullet proof is logarithmic in the
circuit size and Stark is log squared
but there's sort of two orders of
magnitude difference and the log factor
doesn't explain that what does explain
it is bullet proof actually has like
super small concrete multiplier in front
of the the the the Big O hides like 50
bytes or something so it's very nice and
and six inked and the other one is
higher acts in this case is it goes as
cube root of the circuit size
asymptotically but concretely it looked
nothing like cube root and
reason is that one of the low order
terms in the asymptotics is actually
what's dominating at the at these at
these sizes so it looks almost flat okay
so that's proof sighs how about to prove
her time so this is prove our time
single-threaded which we can think of as
sort of the total amount of work that it
takes to generate a proof and I should
say that some of these systems can can
run in multi-threaded for example the
stark implementation can handle dozens
or hundreds of threads and that's like a
suite like when you actually want to
generate a proof but it makes it hard to
compare things so here we're just
looking at single threaded so remember
on the last slide ZK boo had really big
proofs and bullet proof had really small
proofs but here we see that the the
fortunes are sort of reversed zkb is
like super super quick and bullet proof
is you know it's a little more a little
slower a little more challenging and
then between the extremes we kind of
have maybe we can think of it as two
strata the more expensive ones are
higher accent Aurora and then the less
expensive ones are I guess this is what
ZK sorry Leigh here Oh a Libra and lip
snark kind of a little better than the
median so I should note a couple things
here first
lib snark in this case is not the
universal version this is the one that
uses a perk computation trusted setup
we're gonna see concretely what the cost
is of the universal version later but
here we're just looking at per
computation trusted setup and the other
thing that we should be asking is what
is actually the cost of that trusted
setup and the answer is roughly speaking
you can think about the cost of the
trusted setup and Lib snark as about 2x
the cost of running a single proof so it
looks very similar okay and then the
last thing I haven't told you about is
the verifier performance so lib snark
has short proofs and extremely fast
verification and the reason for that is
that there is this trusted you know
pre-processing step so a lot of the work
is happening in the pre-processing step
in contrast if we look at something like
bulletproof there's no pre-processing at
all and so the verifier as part of
verification actually has to read the
whole computation that the the
you know that it's verifying and so this
ends up meaning that there's some linear
cost and actually that cost involves
public key crypto so this explains sort
of the concrete costs but now we should
be stopping and thinking for a second
because I said a couple slides ago that
everyone except Lib snark is free of
trusted setup and yet there are plenty
of verifiers on this slide that are
sublinear somehow so what's going on
what's going on is the sub-linear
verifiers that don't require trust it's
setup are taking advantage of some
structure in the circuit so as a couple
examples Stark has a model which
requires essentially expressing the
computation as the repeated application
of a state machine transformation so the
reason that the verifier can think about
that very quickly is because the the
description of the state machine
transformation is very small or in the
case of say Libra or hyrax or Leggero
they can take advantage of the fact that
the verifier the the verification
circuit is actually in this case many
many evaluations of shot 256 so there's
a common structure there and all of them
can extract that common structure and
then let's see so Aurora and bulletproof
sorry Aurora bulletproof send zkb plus
plus are sort of in the boat where
they're not taking advantage of
structure although certainly in the case
of bulletproof sim possibly in case of
the others there is some possibility for
taking advantage of structure say
batching the same the proof of the same
computation many times and I don't
picture sonic here but in that case I
think we'll see this in the next talk
there's this possibility to take
advantage of an untrusted helper who
batches together solution proofs for
many different statements and there we
end up with you know a similar thing
where incrementally the cost is you know
sub-linear for is constant for each for
each proof okay so we have some notion
of how these things perform concretely
so let's to go back and take a look at
the front end now
so remember the front end is going to
convert our computation Phi into some
representation and so we can kind of
slice the front ends in two different
ways we can either think about the
machinery that it uses to actually
compile from a high-level language into
a representation or we can think about
the representation
that it's actually targeting right and
so we'll start there let's think about
the representation so I've alluded I
think a couple slides ago to like two
different approaches here the first one
is roughly to translate the computation
into an unrolled finite state machine so
essentially running the program on a cpu
where the the computation is the fetch
decode execute loop of the CPU and so
this is the approach that BC GTV 13 BC
TV 14 a and BC TV 14 BC TV 15 they take
this approach and they they introduced
the tiny Ram architecture and and the
idea there is really beautiful because
it kind of sidesteps
the problem that in the Pinocchio style
protocols you have to run a per
computation setup so here the
computation is just the CPU and then we
can compile our program using any
compiler I think actually BC tv-14 I
actually modified GCC so they could just
run their run their program through GCC
and then they run the program as
software on the emulated CPU which is
super cool so the only downside to this
is that there is some cost associated
with it again we'll see it in a little
bit vram that's this one zg k PP 18
takes a similar approach but they go
they take advantage of the fact that the
setup in in their scenario is not per
computation which means that they can
actually optimize the CPU on-the-fly for
the program so that's that's kind of
super cool and actually start to take a
similar approach but for different
reasons I mentioned in stark we want to
be able to apply the same transition
function many times so there we have to
sort of get a concise description of the
transition function and so we end up
with something very much like a fetch
decode execute loop or in some cases
explicitly a fetch decode execute loop
okay so if that's a CPU then we can
think of basically every other work as
being an FPGA so the idea is we're gonna
translate the program line by line into
a circuit and so it's so actually there
are a few systems where it's worth
noting the shape of the circuit also
matters not just the contents so the the
GKR derived circuits want a wide and
shallow circuit because depth figures
into the costs
and so in all of the circuit ish and all
the FPGA ish cases there's sort of
something like unrolling the execution
of the CPU here it is that the
computation time turns into space in the
circuit and it's it's actually even
worse than that because things like
conditionals actually turn into space
where all the conditionals get executed
and then we select the one the one that
we wanted but actually it gets even
slightly worse than that because so I'm
saying here eyes ero greater than equal
to five remember this is basically
turning into an arithmetic circuit and
there's no really concise way of
expressing i0 greater than equal to five
in an arithmetic circuit so what do we
do well okay so what we do is we ask the
prover to convince us that i0 is greater
than equal five by giving us a bitwise
expansion of the difference so we're
gonna call I for I 0 minus 5 so give me
please I say to the prover the bitwise
expansion of this value and then first I
have to check that it's actually the
correct bitwise expansion so I I compute
you know I compare the two and then I
have to check that all the bits are
actually bits they're either 1 or 0
which I do by checking that either you
know 1 times 1 minus is 0 okay and then
finally I check them effectively the
most significant bit of the bitwise
expansion and you know sort of in two's
complement fashion if that's 0 then I
know it's positive and that means that a
0 is greater than equal to 5 so this
blows up a lot right if I have a K bit
number then I need something like k plus
3 constraints and this is true for
comparisons for arbitrary modular
reductions there are a lot of these
things that we think of as kind of
natural computations on a cpu that are
actually very unnatural in this model
and I want to be clear that I'm picking
a little bit on the FPGA people here but
but the the tiny RAM and the the the CPU
style of computations also pay this cost
it's just sort of in the cpu state
transition function so in there there's
bitwise expansions for things like the
end function or the you know XOR okay so
let's okay so this is sort of the
representations another thing as I said
that we can look at is how the compilers
themselves work and this is the last one
of these taxonomy but but here
this is sort of there's a trade-off
space between expressiveness and cost
and so we can roughly you can see this
as sort of a frontier where up into the
right is a little better so the very
lowest costs come from systems that do
some sort of special-purpose computation
so Thaler 13 is a good example there's
an a superfast matrix multiplication
proof protocol there
it's special-purpose it's also super
high performance another example is V
sequel which you know sort of observes
that look sequel queries are essentially
data parallel operations so they use the
the data parallel protocol from Feiler
13 to execute and plus a bunch of other
very co-opt ization to execute the
sequel queries in parallel on all the
rows of the database and then we have
these these sort of gadget libraries
bellman gadget live Lego snark cocoa and
probably some others that are missing
and the idea there is somebody can
develop like a very efficient for
example a crypto primitive and then I
can you know I don't know how to do that
but I can just sort of wire together
these very efficient primitives so there
the goal is to sort of attack the really
hard problems and then let me wire them
together so if we move to the right then
we get we get these these systems that
essentially can can compile pure
computation so no i/o just you know
arithmetic this sort of thing so pepper
ginger cursor comp okay that's our have
that flavor and then as we move up a
little bit allspice does a little more
than that so it does that but then it
also does some program analysis and says
oh maybe this proof system would be
better for this computation or maybe
this proof system would be better for a
different computation and giraffe kind
of goes in that direction too it tries
to slice apart programs and say maybe
this piece is good for outsourcing and
this other piece is bad for outsourcing
and the and the verifier should execute
that locally so so clearly that's not
for zero knowledge but but you can see
how in the outsourcing case we only
bother to outsource the things where the
prover can actually help us as a moving
for the right again now we start to get
into stateful computations so pantry add
snark Geppetto and XJ snarky an
approximately increasing order of speed
can can work with memory with i/o and
they're essentially the way that it
works is they're sort of commitment
coming in and then computations over the
commitments and a new commitment going
out so we can sort of have verified
operations on state and then finally all
the rate of the right is the systems
that work essentially in the CPU issue
or the state machine transition model
and we've seen most of these before
except we haven't I haven't mentioned
buffet yet and if I didn't better with
tech I would have moved buffet over a
little bit because it's not quite as
expressive as the others so in buffet
the idea is we can use program analysis
to turn complex control flow into a
custom state machine that only applies
to that one program but it means that we
don't have to pay the overhead of the
CPU we just pay the costs of the one
program and so what this means is
there's no notion of program text in
buffet right so I'm there's no program
memory which means I can't do things
like function pointers or or
self-modifying code so it is restricted
compared to these other systems but as
we'll see like in two slides there's a
little bit of a trade-off here so well
here we are so this is this is a
comparison of just the front end so the
back end here is fixed the back end is
Lib snark which is we've saw a little
while ago and and so the three we're
looking at the three approaches here I'm
sorry about the rendering there it looks
a little bad pantry is the it represents
the sort of FPGA approach BC tv-14 a is
VN tiny Ram approach and then buffet is
sort of the hybrid between the two
before we look at this XJ snark I don't
have data for it because it doesn't
quite handle the the sort of state
machine transformation computations but
it does improve on buffets transit
memory handling and things like this by
about 3x and also I should mention vram
it's a different back-end so it's
difficult for to put it on one slide and
kind of make sense of it but it sort of
it uses the CPU abstraction but because
of some very nice optimizations that I
mentioned and also because it's using a
proof system that's a little easier for
the prover it ends up sort of recovering
a lot of the cost of the cpu
abstractions so you can think about vram
as approximately as fast as buffet
except actually on matrix mode
location where it can use justin's
superfast matrix multiplication protocol
okay so those aside what we see is so
matrix multiplication is a great example
of a computation where it just turns
straight into an arithmetic circuit
right and so they're the CPU abstraction
does basically nothing for us and and we
just it costs us a lot but as we start
to get into these computations that that
need to work with state or that have
complicated control flow then the CPU
abstraction starts to really really help
us compared to trying to turn this
complex control flow into a into a flat
circuit but you know in with buffet we
can avoid paying some of the costs of
the of the CPU while still having that
approach where we where we can
comprehend complex control flow with
essentially a state machine this kind of
thing like they would know where these
these three don't do that the one that
does that it I think I mentioned
allspice um yeah so in that case
basically you could imagine adding a
similar program analysis to any of these
but the idea there is basically just
sort of try and compile the circuit and
then apply some model of the cost say
for I believe it uses GKR / CMT as one
of its options and you know Pinocchio
style like Lib snark for the other
option yeah I think you could probably
do it either way but but in fact the way
that it's done there is first we compile
and then we see like is this thing low
depth enough that the costs would be
worthwhile in gkr versus in lip snark
for Pinocchio does that make sense I
think they're what
it's for anytime of the lip snark
proofer yeah sorry thank you for the
question
so everything here is running time
normalized to buffet on this slide so
this is just the prover exactly yeah so
this is only proving roofer and all over
the three yeah actually I think I think
in the BC TV case we didn't have a
compiler that targeted tiny Ram so but
we actually wrote the assembly by hand
but you know it starts from some high
ash level description of the computation
so yeah in all of these cases we have a
computation that's like mergesort
written in C or maybe Han translating it
to assembly but it really is something
that you can run on a normal computer
and then we turn that into a computation
that you would run in in one of these
proof systems does that make sense
[Music]
great question so I think Geppetto
handles certain kinds of computations
better yeah so the as you're pointing
out this is very incomplete so Geppetto
handles computations where they're sort
of state passing between sort of large
sections of a program so it handles that
sort of thing much better
I think it doesn't have the it doesn't
implement the the sort of state machine
to a circuit or rather program to state
machine transformation um which is
really the in some sense what we're
looking at here but if it did then yeah
it would get sort of the same come the
same performance as buffet and then it
would get this ability to sort of very
efficiently pass data between chunks of
a computation
okay so we've looked at this we've
gotten comfortable with it but it's it's
sweeping something pretty unfortunate
under the rug namely we're we're kind of
looking at like two orders of magnitude
at best in in or maybe a few orders of
magnitude at best in terms of
optimizations but if we put native on
the the scale then like suddenly life
doesn't look as good
we're like six orders of magnitude
behind where we where we want to be and
I want to be clear I'm not picking on
these systems and I'm not picking on the
Lib snark back-end here because remember
we looked at this earlier and Lib snark
is actually faster than the median so
like in all of these cases we would have
this huge blow-up maybe it would be four
orders of magnitude instead of six but
like somehow this is kind of a nightmare
it's not a nightmare instead maybe we
should think about this as what I had a
manager who used to use the phrase
opportunity to excel so so I think that
this is an opportunity to excel so okay
so the other reason that maybe we
shouldn't be too depressed is because
there really are cases where we're
willing to pay a lot of proofer time
like I can go to Amazon and rent a
hundred servers so like it's okay if a
computation is big because there are a
lot of processors in the world today and
like somebody else owns them which is
great but maybe there is a different
sense in which we should be depressed
and that is if we look at if we look at
the reachable computation size this
isn't just like how long it would take
this is like can we do it period so to
look at that instead of looking at like
how how long each one takes on a fixed
program size let's look at how much work
we can get done sorry how long each one
takes on yeah the same program let's
look at how much work we can get done
for a fixed circuit size right and so
here I'm fixing it at 10 million gates
which is about what you need on you know
a reasonable computer that has like 16
or 32 gigs of RAM and so if we do that
then what we see is that we we can we
can get support up to I don't know like
a 500 element merge sort which is like I
mean you fire a Python and do that like
you don't even think about it or like a
202 and remai tricks multiplication like
we do that in MATLAB and don't again
it's like a millisecond whereas the
prover takes 20 minutes to generate the
proof so like we should be we should be
a little worried that we maybe can't
reach
sizes that we really would care about
but I should say that VRAM pushes that
up by another order of magnitude so so
things are getting better we're getting
we're getting bigger but but another but
we could ask like what else could we do
and maybe there's some intuition and
what I just said like I can rent a
hundred servers from Amazon so why don't
we try doing that and that's exactly the
question that we would all ask with the
the dizzy cord distributed zero
knowledge work and the answer is well
let's just throw more computers at it
and so we're gonna run the prover as a
distributed computation now instead of
on a single machine and that is way
easier said than done
so the dezik tepid targets the the
Pinocchio ish Lib snark kind of back-end
and they're in inside of the the QAP
there's this giant FFT that we need to
compute and and unfortunately it turns
out that like distributing the FFT is
like a totally totally non-trivial
problem but fortunately there was some
work by say in in 2011 in the context of
multiplying like terabit integers in a
MapReduce cluster so this is a
distributed computation where we end up
with two batches each of size square
root n where each work each piece of
work in the batch works over a
computation of size square root and so
there's a concrete blow up there but and
there's actually a lot of communication
between the two batches but the nice
thing is that while these tasks are
executing it's all local computation
that's only about square root n size so
this is like a huge huge advantage for
us for one of these proofs so disick
takes this approach and the results that
they show are super cool so they show
100x larger reachable instances compared
to you know the this former state of the
art and so in particular on their
cluster they could get sort of a million
ish constraints with one one computer
and a couple billion with with well a
couple hundred computers but that's like
easy to rent from Amazon like I go there
and I click a button and like a hundred
computers just materialize so this might
seem like a lot but actually no this is
like your web browser can do this to
first order and it costs like 20 bucks
an hour or something so it's like great
and the other question we could ask is
like how fast is it and this is showing
us sort of speed versus the number of of
workers and if
if we draw a vertical lines that kind of
tells us how its scaling so if for
example if we just look at like how long
it takes for workers to do something and
how long it takes 64 workers to do
something we really are going from like
you know hours to minutes to run these
things which is cool so so this means
maybe there's hope even just with sort
of System z work to scale these things
up to two computations that are big
enough to really get done what we care
about doing and so having said that
let's take a look at some computations
there's some applications that maybe we
care about yeah so in the case of disick
there yeah there this is a great point
the the prover there it really is all
200 machines and so each machine gets to
see at least a little piece of the
witness so there's no statement of you
know the witness is hidden or something
like this so yeah this is actually this
is a question that we could hope to
answer is can we get this without
trusting the cluster yeah I agree with
you I agree with you thank you it's a
great point I'm sorry okay
so let's take a look at some
applications so we weren't going to get
out of this without talking about
cryptocurrencies
but the reason for that is that there's
a lot of a lot of cool applications in
the cryptocurrency space so an obvious
one that I think we all probably know
about is Z cash so it's based on a paper
from 2014 zero cash I think was in the
title and it uses essentially proofs as
transactions and roughly speaking what
that means is that your transaction
doesn't reveal who you are and it
doesn't reveal how much you've spent
which is cool and in fact there are
there are efforts to incorporate this
same kind of idea into other blockchain
so Greg Maxwell I think proposed
confidential transactions and they're
building them on top of bulletproof
another application that I think is
super exciting is coda which is a
project from order one labs and the idea
there is to use recursive proof
composition so that if you want to
verify the whole blockchain all you do
is download like 20 kilobytes and then
verify one proof and you've got the
whole history verified in one go and so
that's already cool but I think the
thing that may be the lesson that we can
draw from that is that like there are
now
our applications where we can start to
hope using like recursive proof
composition in a practical way and we
should be excited about this because
this is like a new a new tool a new
weapon that we should be deploying to to
get some of these applications and then
I can't resist mentioning one more it is
illustrative so I've some work with Dan
brunet and Chris Jeffries and Joseph
Boone on what are called private air
drops so here the idea is I'm gonna give
you money but you don't want to reveal
that you took the money
so instead there's some like privacy
aspect there and I'm not gonna go into
details except to point out that this is
not a general-purpose proof system and
we actually looked at how much it would
cost if we just wanted to implement this
in sort of the straightforward way with
any of the general purposes your
knowledge proof systems that we could
hope to use and the answer was it was
very very expensive so the I think the
lesson to take away from this is we like
in within this design space there are
also these specialized proof systems
that we should go to first if we can if
your statement is simple try try very
hard to use something specialized
because you'll save orders of magnitude
it turns out at least in this case okay
but there there's I wanna go into a
little more detail about one other
cryptocurrency application and it's
called roll-up and from what I know it
was suggested by somebody called Barry
White hat so the setting is I want to
build a bank out of a smart contract and
so the way this is gonna work is when
Alice wants to send Bob money she signs
a transaction and sends it to the bank
and then you know maybe Bob and Carol do
the same thing and the picture that I'm
painting here is bad for a couple
reasons so one the smart contract has to
verify all of those signatures and doing
that means that the smart contract has
to burn money and it also has to pay for
the data transfer and on top of that
it's gonna be extremely slow so as
written this doesn't work but here comes
the roll-up idea so the idea is what if
we add in a third party this is an
untrusted third party called an
aggregator and so now when when when
Alice Bob and Carol want to transact
what they do is they send their
signature to the aggregator and then
periodically the aggregator is going to
create a batch of these transactions and
summarize them in one proof and send
that proof to the smart contract and
then all the smart contract has to do is
check that one
so obviously we're relying on the
aggregator here for liveness and also
for privacy and those are additional
opportunities to excel but but we can
think about like this is kind of an
interesting verifiable outsourcing
looking application where we're
additionally using the zero knowledge
property almost to get data compression
so you can also alternatively think
about this as you know one level of
proof recursion signatures or a proof
and then there's a proof about the
proofs but but you know the idea here is
actually it's very nice and it turns out
it's quite practical um okay so that's
that's one application totally separate
application not in the blockchain space
now is an idea from SETI angel group
timely at OS di 18 and this is called
spice so the idea here is I want to
build something like stripe or or we pay
or something like this where I can send
money to people it's sort of by
connecting to the central server and
then the central server has like some
database or some backing store and it's
it's storing all the transactions in the
backing store but what I want to do is I
want this to be auditable so every once
in a while the the service should send
out some proof that it's been working
correctly and in principle we could have
done this based on existing thing well
not we they could have done this based
on existing things like pantry or V
sequel which both support these verified
storage primitives but the problem here
is specifically with getting concurrency
because we want to be able to have so
for example if we used pantry then you
have a commitment to the current state
of the world and Ana proof transitions
us to the next state of the world and
there's no way to do that multiple times
in parallel so we want to be able to do
this concurrently um so to get this the
author's draw on some work in the in the
memory checking literature and they
design what they call a batch of
verifiable set based key value store
lots of hyphens um so the idea in the
top left of this of this diagram is we
start with some state of the world that
is expressed as two sets a read set and
a write set and anytime that somebody
reads or writes to the store that
updates the the sets and then later we
can check that all of the reads
correctly serviced from previous rights
just by checking that the read set is a
subset of the right set okay I'm not
gonna prove that to you but that's the
idea and so this is like somehow it
doesn't catch for example which read was
done incorrectly it only asserts yes all
the reads were done incorrectly or no
there was at least one error but in this
in this service model maybe that's good
enough and then on top of that we can
use a zero knowledge proof to make this
statement you know into a compact and
obviously your knowledge thing and then
that is actually what we send to the
auditor so that we can tell the auditor
sort of every ten minutes or something
yes everything was fine in the last ten
minutes and so the results
performance-wise are like you know four
orders of magnitude better than than
what what could be done previously so to
me this is a nice lesson in like taking
advantages of the strengths of the tools
and the weaknesses or at least avoiding
the weaknesses so here the the zero
knowledge proof scheme is being used to
implement business logic which it's
great at and then on top of that there's
this additional piece of like a
concurrency primitive that's enough to
get you know to get the application to
work so maybe we can think about this as
sort of a point between full generality
and and you know application specificity
where we take what we need from each one
okay one final application and I'll go
through this one quickly what if we want
to build trusted hardware and so this is
a question that we started from some
coffers I'm sorry for a moment I
apologize it's on this like a few years
ago and so the question is like okay I
want to build a chip for a firewall and
I want to make sure that even though I
don't own the the the company that's
actually building the chip like I design
it but then I send it off to you know
TSMC or somebody and maybe maybe they're
gonna insert some backdoor into the chip
and for example maybe the backdoor will
listen for some secret sequence of
packets and then let an attacker or you
take over my phone and this mmm-maybe
seems like paranoia except I think this
article is from 2012 and it the claim
was that already we should be worried
about these about counterfeit they're
impossibly malicious devices and so the
US government for example is very
worried about this and they have a
special program that is there to try and
detect and prevent attacks of this sort
and to do that they make sure that all
the contractors have background checks
and they you know they have like chains
of custody and couriers for the designs
that are going from the you know design
house to the fab and the reason for all
of this sort of activity is that there's
been a lot of work in the in the last
few years on attacking chips like
inserting backdoors into chips and the
high level message is that we can that
you can do this essentially with
impunity if you're the one building the
chip you can put a backdoor in it and no
one will ever know so the this idea of
having a trusted fab though isn't so
great because well there are only a few
places in the world where you can
actually build really fast processors
and if we want to start doing that here
like we're gonna spend ten billion
dollars and then maybe in five years
we'll be able to make some processors or
maybe the fab you know won't work and
we'll have to spend another year like
Intel's been um so the alternative is I
can just go and buy an old fab it's
cheap no one really wants it anymore
but then the physics of semiconductor
scaling starts to kill me because now I
pay like eight orders of magnitude and
in performance so the idea in in in this
application that we call verifiable
Asics is we're just going to apply the
outsourcing regime to chips so
specifically remember we have our
computation Phi and what we're gonna do
is we're gonna actually turn it into two
chips one called the prover and one
called the verifier and the prover we're
gonna build at TSMC or whoever makes the
fastest chips today and the verifier
we're gonna build at our own private
trusted fab and then we'll put them
together and then this is the device
that we actually run so when i want to
run a computation the verifier you know
talks to the prover and i get out an
answer that i believe is correct and so
so the question like the high-level
question is like does this work I mean
I'm claiming it's an application so what
does it look like so this is some
simulations we haven't built any chips
yet of elliptic curve point
multiplication and here the prover is in
like today's technology like seven
nanometer and the verifier is in like
you know twenty or twenty five year old
technology like quarter micron and so
what we're looking at is energy cost so
on the y-axis is the energy that it
takes to run the batch of computations
and on the x-axis is sort of the number
of computations we run in parallel and
the base line these blue dots is just
running the computation on the trusted
chip so what we see is that it's sort of
after 30 parallel computations or so we
actually can beat the native base line
so this is this is an instance where we
can do where we can do like verifiable
outsourcing and and actually get some
benefit and maybe we view that as a
positive result and and roll up is
another example of a positive result but
but actually when we started working on
this we kind of set out to answer this
question like does it ever make sense to
outsource and this is an instance of
where it does but it's almost depressing
that you have to go this far to find
something where it works right like this
is a very specialized case yeah so here
this is in this is an approved system
where the the verification cost
eventually like asymptotically ends up
tracking because we have to sort of
check the sizes and we have to work over
batches that are approximately sorry
inputs that are basically order the size
of the circuit so in this specific
computation there's no sub linearity
this is so the the underlying system is
GKR and eventually baylor 13 here and
the size of the inputs is proportional
the size of the circuit so this is why
the verifier eventually looks
asymptotically just like the size of the
circuit you might hope to take advantage
of like sort of I don't know commitments
or something like this that would make
that better but here we don't on the
corner this is more important than the
other ones from you
I mean I you know I believe it III agree
with you I think that we should be doing
things like this and I'm hoping that we
actually start building ships like this
but on the other hand like the original
dream was you know a laptop
controlling a herd of supercomputers and
and we haven't quite reached that that
dream yet so in that sense we're still
searching for the the pieces that are
going to get us to you know real
practical outsourcing okay so that's the
end of the applications and now I
promised a little bit of a wish list so
here I'm gonna tell you what everything
I want for Christmas um so its front end
sorry its back end which is a meant
front and wishes and some of them are
serious and some of them are systems II
so I hope everyone gets a wish that they
can that they can work on so in the
front and the back end the first wish is
that we can start to avoid using FFTs
they're currently a major bottleneck in
QAP based and IOP based systems and to
be clear my goal is not to impugn the F
of T because it's somehow the crown
jewel of 20th century math or 19th
century math depending on who you ask
but it's just I want to observe that
like f of T's like if we're doing an FFT
over something the size of the circuit
then we're never going to get past the
quasi-linear barrier right we're always
going to be at FML yeah so
asymptotically we should worry about
this and also concretely we should worry
about this because it's memory and it's
communication intensive and look disick
distributes it successfully
but like the amount of work that it took
maybe we could hope to avoid in the
future so that's which number one yeah
absolutely
so it may be that really the answer is
not avoiding it but only applying it to
very small pieces of the computation
absolutely absolutely
second wish and this echoes something
that you've all said is I wish for super
16 super efficient multi linear
polynomial commitments without trusted
set up a lot um so right now any of the
zero knowledge systems that are based on
the interactive proofs or multi prove
interactive proofs are kind of
bottlenecked by their polynomial
commitment scheme so for example in
hyrax the verifier kind of pays a square
root cost in the size of the witness for
the commitment scheme
if we want to shrink the the proof then
the verifiers work goes up to linear in
V sequel and vram and Libra
the performance is great but instead we
pay for a trusted set up so it would be
nice if we could get the best of both
worlds and I think if we had that as you
pointed out we would immediately get
super efficient zero knowledge proof
schemes a third wish is I think another
one that you've all pointed out is MPC
in the head beyond the square root
barrier so I think one of the key
takeaways I thought from the the prover
performance slides was zkb + + + Leggero
are both super fast and on top of that
they have very very minimal complexity
or cryptographic assumptions so this is
the the main thing that we should start
to worry about is like well hmm the
proofs are a little big so I hope maybe
for a positive answer to the question
can we break that the square root
barrier and still keep the SuperSpeed
and the the nice assumptions and then
the final wish for the backend is for
systems that have updatable structured
reference strings like Sonic 2 also have
updatable proofs so let me explain what
I mean so in remember in Sonic I have a
reference string and you don't trust it
so you update the reference string and
now you trust that one but if I
generated a proof with my reference
string then you need to keep my
referencing around in order to check
that proof it would be really nice if we
could have sort of an untrusted process
by which proofs over old reference
strings get updated in two proofs over
the new reference string and you could
see how immediately that would make this
this sort of model extremely extremely
powerful there is some work on this I
was just gonna point out that held your
live MA has some work on this for a
restricted class of computations and so
the question is really like how general
can we get but probably if we think
about it carefully we can't hope to get
too general or too efficient at this
because otherwise it would be equivalent
to getting rid of the trusted setup
entirely I think
from them that's fine Jamie sorry any
very few and sqk me depends random
Oracle model so nothing specifically was
targeted for them we have some
instructions the designation is it's
much bigger for example signatures so
this is you know maybe item you know
item 5a is a good model and item 5b is a
construction for that mark right I mean
opportunities okay so back end how about
the front end so the first wish is
moving beyond the arithmetic circuit
model of computation so we've already
seen that some works do tiny Ram vram
stark they point the way for us but
there are a lot of computations that we
consider natural shot 256 X or veteran
that are ugly when we turn them into
into arithmetic circuits so actually in
this very spot four years ago mike had
exactly the same wish and his suggestion
at the time was that we should start
making friends with the programming
languages folks and he was right we
should have been making friends back
then and we should also now start making
friends with the compiler spokes and
with the formal methods folks because my
final wish is
for compilers and automated front ends
that are targeting all of the new
backends that the area's been producing
so right now the back-end landscape
we've seen a little bit already is like
is kind of fragmented and that's great
because it's a result of the growth but
it's also bad because it means that like
it's very hard for any given back-end to
actually generate a computation that's
really good for that back-end or
generate a representation rather that's
good for that back-end so the result is
everyone kind of tends to hand tune for
their own backends and so then we
there's little common ground where we
can actually compare things so instead I
think what we need to be doing is
systematizing all of that implicit
knowledge that everyone has about how to
tune for their system right and all of
this should be made automated and I
think that will pay dividends in two
different ways so first that'll mean
that people outside the area can
reasonably start to use these systems
because you know the backend once you
give it a representation for the most
part it just works but getting to a
representation from the computation that
you want is a real struggle and there
are we've seen already there are a
couple community projects trying to do
this there sir common bellman and I hope
to maintain an open source project that
that's derived from the buffet compiler
and we get lots of messages on github
and like emails saying like can you help
me do this thing so people really do
want to do this and I think the problem
really is and just getting the front end
to do what you want so the other way I
think this will pay dividends is inside
the research area because it'll mean
that we can compare results in a more
sensible way and it'll ant let us kind
of answer the real question that we
should always be asking when we evaluate
you know a practical system like this
which is for the computation that I care
about what's the best performance that I
can get and and which system should I
use to get it because remember what I
said at the very beginning like I don't
know a million slaves ago is that like
the design space is huge right and this
is good because it means that for any
you know application that we care about
probably there is a point point in the
space where we can like have a very good
answer for that application and it's
true that the absolute costs are pretty
high right now but I think as we've seen
that there's like current and near
future applications that work right now
and the costs are justified and so we
need to make that space bigger and for
that we've all got still
a lot of work to do but maybe not till
after lunch so the thing that you did
with the a6 or the Puma ver apparently
so those workers are going to back to 88
with a proposal and then there's work
like I think Ron and Justin where rather
than having it as a single cooler there
to preserve the separation between them
and I think it feels much more efficient
absolutely and I think we could even I
mean maybe the implicit observation
there is that model actually works
pretty well in the hardware setting
because I can turn one of the chips off
right so like maybe I really can get
strong separation between the provers so
yeah I think you're absolutely right it
would be one of the directions that
would be very cool in a verifiable Asics
world is to start looking at what else
we can do with multiple provers for
example
guess it's lunchtime thanks really
[Applause]
[Music]